dans le contexte de la publication d'un
rapport du renseignement américain qui
vient accusé la russie d'avoir manipulé
une fois de plus les élections
présidentielles américaines joe biden a
été invité à s'exprimer sur vladimir
poutine et le moins que l'on puisse dire
c'est qu'il a eu des mots extrêmement
forts à l'encontre du président russe
vous pensez que vladimir poutine est un
tueur
oui je le pense quel prix doit-il payer
le prix qu'il doit payer
vous le verrez rapidement première
réaction à cette attaque verbale contre
vladimir poutine elle vient de
viatcheslav volodine le président de la
douma
et d'après lui avec cette déclaration
joe biden insulte l'ensemble des
citoyens de la russie par sa déclaration
joe biden a insulté les citoyens de
notre pays
c'est une crise de nerfs provoqué par
l'impuissance
poutine est notre président et les
attaques contre lui constituent les
attaques contre notre pays
un peu plus tôt le porte parole du
kremlin avait également réagi à la
publication de ce rapport du
renseignement américain et avait démenti
en bloc toute ingérence de la part de la
russie
nous sommes en désaccord avec les
conclusions tirées dans ce rapport à
l'égard de notre pays
la russie n'a pas pratiquer l'ingérence
dans l'élection précédente ni dans
l'élection de 2020 mentionnés dans ce
rapport la russie on n'a rien à voir
avec aucune campagne contre aucun
candidat
ça y est on le sait désormais de façon
classique dorénavant de nouvelles
sanctions vont être adoptées contre la
russie on en saura un peu plus sur le
détail sur le contenu de ces sanctions
lors de la journée de jeudi par contre
rarement un président américain avait eu
des propos aussi agressif aussi véhément
contre vladimir poutine est sans aucun
doute cette déclaration va laisser des
traces